now that you've heard all nominated
songs it's time to announce who will
receive the Oscar for original song just
to refresh your memories here are the
five selections from Shrek to
accidentally in love music by Adam
Duritz Charles Gillian Jim Volga's
David I'm reg lovers Matthew Mele and
David Bryson lyric by Adam series
Daniel victory from The Motorcycle
Diaries electro electro del Rio
music plant music and lyric by Jorge
Drexler from The Polar Express believe
music and lyric by Glen Ballard and Alan
Silvestri's from the Phantom of the
Opera learned to be lonely music by
Andrew Lloyd Webber lyric by Charles
Hart from the course look to your path
music by bruno coulais lyric by Krista
Robert Tina and the Oscar goes to
Jorge Drexler for all motorcycle
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Jorge Drexler
clavo me Ramon el agua de voto Ramon el
NiO creo que visto una Luz al otro lado
del Rio LD a Lehrer a pudy endo poco a
poco el frío creo que visto una luz al
otro lado del Rio ciao
Thank You gracias ow
last year he took home the Oscar for
performance by an actor in a leading
role welcome Sean Penn
you